a fire inside a shopping mall crowded
with families killed at least 64 people
in Russia the fire broke out yesterday
the first weekend of a school break and
burned through the night young children
are among the victims Elizabeth Palmer
is following developments from London
Elizabeth good morning good morning it's
a very sad story as you said the fire
broke out late Sunday afternoon and
blazed on well after midnight as
firefighters raced to evacuate people
from the fourth floor of that building
the roofs of two of the three movie
theaters inside eventually collapsed and
in their desperation to escape some
people jumped from windows bodies were
still being discovered in the ruins this
morning the dead include children as the
fourth floor of the mall had featured a
petting zoo and a skating rink as well
as a playroom in fact russia state news
agency is reporting that the fire may
have started in a foam rubber trampoline
in that children's playroom cell phone
video from inside the burning building
shows rescue workers struggling in vain
to break down an internal door Russian
authorities have now launched a criminal
investigation
after witnesses reported that the fire
alarm did not work and access to the
movie theaters had been blocked
gaile very tragic story there thank you
very much Elizabeth